If I had to start over trading, these
are the 10 tricks I wish I knew when I
first started. The first few are really
important for your trading, but the last
ones, those are really the ones that
took me from being an unprofitable
trader to consistently profitable. My
trading got a 100 times better after I
learned these 10 trading tricks. When I
first started trading, I constantly
heard the term that the trend is your
friend and you want to trade with the
trend. Anytime I would see big momentum
moves like this, I would think, okay,
the market is going to the upside. I
need to figure out how to buy and get in
to the long side. And instead, what that
would do a lot of the time is I would
buy in because I was trying to catch the
move to the upside and instead it would
reverse on me, knocking me out and
making a losing trade. And when I
started to shift my mind thinking of
taking the counter trend trades in the
market, I drastically improved my win
rate and was able to spot high
probability setups where I would be
seeing that the market would go up and
then I would bet that it was going to
reverse that and instead of being the
person that would be getting caught, I
would be catching people and capturing
big wins to the downside. And this goes
into the second thing I started doing
that really helped is looking for
uncommon patterns in the market.
Everyone is always looking for your
basic horizontal support, you know,
double top following the current trend
and buying off of when it comes to a
trend line. If everyone's doing that,
it's not going to work. And instead,
what I started to notice is wait for it
to come up to a level like this and do a
fake out or what I call a failed
breakout where it broke the previous
highs of a strong resistance zone
getting people long making them think
it's going to keep going higher and it
said it flips on them. Now, as I just
wait for it to fail back in and then
capture a potential move to the other
side. comparing that trade to this trade
here is the old trade I used to take is
look I'm looking for a double bottom
here and I'm buying the market and
another thing that really helps my
trading is looking for exhaustive moves
to one side waiting for the market to
get overextended instead of having a
methodical trend that's unlikely for the
market to make a solid move in one
direction. Comparing that to this trade
right here, you can see it's chopped
around and then exploded in one
direction. Make it likely that if it
reverses that, it does it quickly and in
a big way, allowing a big opportunity
for you to capture. And so instead of
looking for those basic common patterns
that you see people constantly talking
about, look for these more specific
patterns where the market is at
extremes. You want to trade based on
extremes in the market because that's
where the biggest opportunity is. Now,
the third thing is check out this trade
right here. I have entered in long here
after it's made this clean double
bottom. There's been some strong selling
pressure that I think big picture-wise
is going to reverse the market higher.
The thing I used to do is I would just
leave my trade on, you know, put my stop
loss where it is, put my profit target
where it is, and say, "Okay, I'm just
going to let the trade play out. If I
got two times my risk here and get, you
know, $2,000 in profit, great. And if my
trade loses, it loses." But I have found
over time, the best thing that you can
start doing is when you're in the trade
a while, the best trades happen quickly.
Just like that last trade we looked at,
it went up, it kind of chopped around
for a minute and then it puked back
lower. And so this trade right here,
it's gone down, it's made a double
bottom. This momentum, you would think,
is okay, if it's going to get going,
this is a really solid buying
opportunity and it should just skyrocket
to the upside. And so instead of just
skyrocketing and getting going, it
starts to chop around, which, you know,
makes a little sense. It's probably
going to find some minor resistance at
this area. But if it starts to chop
around too long and start to sell off,
you have to take into account what the
market is doing and the market is
showing that okay, it's made a pullback
here and this is the last kind of thing
I would want to see. If it pulls back
here and goes higher, great. But if it
doesn't, you need to get out of the
trade. And so at that point, I move my
stop essentially to break even. I keep
it above this low extreme just to kind
of follow the price action. What you
want to start doing is when you're in a
trade and it makes a signal like this
where it makes essentially a lower high
right here off of an area where it could
potentially slow down and reverse, you
got to get out. You cannot get married
to the trade hoping that it's going to
become profitable. It's better to get
out because the market's really telling
you clear signals that hey, we're just
in kind of a choppy range at the moment
and it's better to just get out. If it
was going to work out, it would have
worked out by now. but instead, you
know, it chops us out. But it doesn't
matter because you're at break even.
Now, if you don't have anything to
analyze chart patterns, I highly
recommend getting Ninja Trader. I have
used it for over 5 years now, and it is
an extremely powerful platform with a
ton of indicators, add-ons, allowing you
to enter and exit trades seamlessly. You
can check it out in the link in
description or this QR code. Now,
something that lost me a ton of money
when it came to trading was doing things
like revenge trading or trading too long
or when I get in a loss, you know,
taking more trades trying to, you know,
make the money back or just trading when
I was too tired. What you need to do is
have a structure to your trading. Have a
schedule you are following. Every day
for me, I wake up at about 6:30 and I'm
on looking at the charts by about 7 or
7:15. The market opens up at 7:30 my
time. And so from about 7:30 is when the
market opens. I'm looking for my
specific pattern. What you want to be
doing is you want to go into every day
looking for a specific pattern. And so
for me, I trade from about 7:30 to
sometimes this trade only lasted till
about 8:00. I was done in about 45
minutes. But if I trade longer, I, you
know, trade maybe an hour and a half,
take a break, and then trade another
hour. But that's how I'm able to
consistently execute a strategy over
time because if you're doing the same
thing constantly, you will know when
certain things are off. You want to know
when you are frustrated, when you're too
tired, or when you're just not seeing
the market right. Having a specific stop
time or rules on when you're going to
stop, like if you take too many losses
in a day or if you lose too much
moneywise, that is going to really help
you not have days where you blow up your
account. Because for me, the biggest
thing when I first started trading was
having days where I lost way more than I
won because I just went on a revenge
trading spree. And that goes into this
next trick of focusing on trading in the
big picture. Every day is going to be
different. Some days are great for your
trading strategy and some days suck
where either there's no trading
opportunities or it's just the market's
really hard to read and you need to
learn to just not trade during those
days when the market is super choppy
like this. For a really clearer example
is you can see the market's just back
and forth. And even when the market
opens here, the candlesticks, if you
look, are just all next to each other.
There's no clean moves in one direction.
Look, this is the first 30 minutes of
movement right here. And if I go back to
this trade on this day, this is the
first 30 minutes on a different day. And
you can see this is way more tradable.
And so what you want to do is you don't
want to be going into trading trying to
force trades on days like this where the
market is just crappy and all over the
place and just not moving because the
opportunity isn't there. Trading is not
about making money every day. It's about
making money over the long run. And most
of the time you're going to have a
couple days that make your month. You're
going to be making consistent trades
maybe every other day or something
depending on how your strategy is. But
you're going to have a couple of trades
that really are massive and make the
rest of your month. And so make sure to
focus on the idea that okay, approach
the day that is this a good trading day
or not and do I want to even sit around
for it or do I just need to be patient,
take a break maybe and then come back if
it starts to move. The next really key
thing is trade during peak market times
where volume is the biggest the biggest
time that I've noticed at least trading
the S&P 500 is the first couple hours of
the day is the highest volume and the
highest movement where the bigger
opportunities are and then about the
last hour of the trading day is where
the biggest opportunities are as well.
That's how most markets run no matter
where you are in the world. So, if
you're at a different time zone where,
you know, maybe trading the S&P 500 and
the main US stock market doesn't really
work, you can trade other important
market sessions like the Asian or the
Australian or the European. All those
are going to allow you to have times
where those markets are moving
drastically and creating good
opportunities. Something that also
damaged my trading in the beginning was
trying to capture every move or swing in
the market. This is really impossible
when it comes to trading. And so what I
found over time for me that really
worked was focus on the extremes. This
really goes with those initial patterns
we were talking about of looking at when
the market's at an extreme in terms of
those patterns and those smaller
movements, but also big picture of
looking at, okay, zooming out on a
larger time frame. Where are the
extreme, you know, supply and demand
zones that the market is bouncing off
between? You know, recently in these
past couple of days, it's been going
back and forth between this range right
here. And so anytime it's in the middle
of that range, I stay away. But anytime
it's near the highs, I am really focused
and looking at what's going on because
it's highly likely that with those
areas, it's going to reverse because
that's what it's done before. The market
likes to repeat what it's done before a
lot of the time. That same thing goes
for a choppy market like we had before.
This morning, the market was super
choppy back and forth. And so, I really
didn't take any trades today because I
said, "Oh, well, the market's choppy and
it's likely to continue that." And
essentially, you can see over the rest
of the day, there's been some movement
back and forth, but really not enough to
have good trading opportunities. Another
big factor is using proper riskreward
ratios. I traded really small riskreward
ratios when I first started out and it
really messed up my trading because I
was risking a large amount a lot of the
time to make a small amount and so this
really messed up my riskreward ratio.
What you want instead is I highly
recommend going for about two or three
times your risk. So if you're risking a
h 100red or $1,000, you're going for
$300 or $3,000 because it allows you to
be wrong. And if you look at a table,
the math of it all, if you have a 1:2
risk-reward ratio, you can be break even
at a 30% win rate. And at 50%, you're
making great money. Now, when I first
started trading, I was really excited
about the potential money I could make.
I found a few patterns. I realized that,
you know, the person using them was
really successful doing them. They were
making a ton of money. And I opened up
an account with real money and started
trading right away. And when I didn't
realize that it would take me a long
time to kind of figure out even just the
basics of using a trading platform,
getting those down the consistency of
having a trading schedule and doing it
repeatedly over and over and not getting
bogged down and trying to capture other
moves throughout the day, but instead of
just waiting for that one specific
pattern. And so what I highly recommend
because I've seen traders lose tens of
thousands of dollars because they skip
this step is that you need to start on a
demo account first. Start using Ninja
Trader on a demo account. Practice
whatever strategy you want to practice.
Just get used to the platform because
there's a lot to learn about it. and
allow yourself time to prove to yourself
that you can make consistent money demo
trading. Because if you don't do that
over a couple weeks or even a couple
months, you're going to consistently
lose money when it comes to actually
switching to a real account. Just like
anything, there's a lot of mistakes
you're going to make in the beginning.
And mistakes in trading lose you money.
Just give it a few weeks or a couple
months to get yourself kind of settled
and then you can start trading with real
money. And this really goes into the
last point of treating trading like a
business. You're not doing this for fun.
You are doing this to make consistent
money over time. That's what any
business is. You put in an initial
capital. You risk money by, you know,
let's say opening a restaurant and then
over time you work at it consistently
over and over to start making a profit
over time. But that's not going to
happen right away. Would you really
expect your business, if you start a
restaurant business, to start making a
ton of money right away? Very unlikely.
Usually, a business grows slowly over
time. Treat trading the exact same way.
Focus on the process of what makes it
successful because what that's going to
do is it's going to allow you to build
it properly and it's going to allow you
to focus on the correct things. You do
not want to be going back and forth
constantly when it comes to trading,
losing money, starting a new trading
plan, not having to work, and trying to
constantly learn something else that
might work. You need to stick with
something for a while and focus on the
process of what makes it work. Now, this
is just 10 things I have learned along
my trading career. I've created a full
free 75 list of key lessons I've learned
over my seven years of trading. I highly
recommend getting it either in link in
the description or using this QR code.
Just using the few minutes that it will
take you to read through that list could
save you thousands of dollars. So, I
highly recommend getting that. It's
totally free. And if you want to learn
more about a strategy that I have used
to be consistently profitable over time,
check out this video right here. It'll
go into every detail on what it takes to
become consistently profitable at
scalping.